[Music]
yes
good to see you always thanks for
showing up for these these little
explainer videos
well thanks for doing them you know you
know i you know how i come up with them
there's like
things that people know about but they
don't know as much as they
think they should know or might want to
know after they learned all they could
know
that was very dr seuss
no it's it's i think i know enough about
this and then you realize this stuff you
didn't know and oh my gosh i'm glad i
learned it so
i'm making a judgment there that there's
nothing wrong with going
in-depth it's in-depth total so this one
is something very simple the shape of
craters
shape of craters yeah yeah okay a
picture of the moon
any photograph of the moon right the
shape of the craters
well they're all circle concave little
circles
they're perfect circles every single
one of them the big ones the little ones
the medium ones
they are perfect circles okay
so let's guess let me guess
aliens just like on earth
same way they make the crop circles they
make
moonshine that's how they make the moon
circles
moon circles there so yeah here's the
thing
it's interesting that as humans if
there's something scientists don't
understand
people rapidly just go to god or aliens
well that's why
they got the explanation for white all
right
it turned out it was a mystery
why all craters are perfect circles for
the longest time it was a mystery until
about 100 years ago
okay and let me tell you why it was a
mystery
all right so your first thought is well
the moon doesn't have an atmosphere
maybe it's getting slammed by meteors
okay but is every meteor coming
straight down at a 90 degree angle so
that
the explode that ready hits it makes it
per is that
surely some of them are at an angle
you'd expect
some craters to be elongated right
and you have all sort of shapes uh from
circle to very
uh very flattened circles you'd expect
that
some of them would be divots like a like
the when you swing a golf
you know it'd just be like a oh okay i
mean it came in on an angle
on the angle from and with the with the
with the because you'd have a
the slope would be different on one side
than the other then on the opposite
because it came
slid in and slid in so you'd expect that
and
it is nowhere to be found on the moon so
this energized the geologists
because we know that the dark areas of
the moon
is where lava has once flowed okay
i think they call it basalt it's dark
and it's
lava fields all right and by the way the
apollo astronauts
aimed for those places because
they're flat if you're gonna go quarter
million mile
and land sideways on and fall over
that's it
all right so they found the flattest
areas and those are called seas
these are um before people knew that the
moon didn't have weather like we have or
oceans these large flat areas were
called see the sea of tranquility
okay that's where it gets its name nice
um and all the c's were named after
psychological states
or physiological states so there's a sea
of fecundity
there's a c all right yeah yeah right so
there's a
anyway but so they're flat because lava
in liquid state flattens out right there
you go okay
all right so wherever there was a crater
it was round
so the geologist said it's probably not
these uh asteroids because they'd have
to all come in perpendicular
they're probably all volcanic craters
because volcanic craters you punch up it
makes a hole the hole is a circle
right okay you know you can pull that
off
so that's that's how it stood
for the longest while until
people saw craters on top
of places where it didn't look like lava
had flowed
okay so how are you gonna have a crater
and no lava signature
anywhere near it what's up with that
and so this was a conundrum okay i have
a book from 1890
and it says um believed by many
to be volcanic in origin uh perhaps
they're
actually of uh asteroid impacts we are
not sure
okay it's by the way it was that way
for most of the 20th century until
computers came along and you could
simulate
impacts nice you want to simulate it
okay so here you go you ready if you
if you have an impactor that comes in uh
straight into a surface it makes a
circular crater
if you send it at an angle it will make
an elongated crater
okay this will happen so they're saying
no wait a minute let's send it in
faster turns out
there is a magic speed
with which you can send in an asteroid
and on collision it will make a perfect
circle no matter the angle
it hits no matter the angle it hits
correct and that's speed okay
this is this is what okay you ready let
me guess let me guess
88 miles per hour
precisely the same speed that it takes
to propel you into the future
because the flux capacitors
89 miles per hour all right so
here's the so here's what's going on
let's let's take a rock
and you can ask why does the rock sort
of hang together
right why isn't it just decomposed into
sand
well because they're molecules that are
attached all right
it's molecularly attached within itself
right right these are electromagnetic
forces you can
we know what they are okay um
all right you can add up how much energy
is contained in all of these molecular
bonds
okay and you come write down that number
and you say this rock is held together
by this much energy
you can do that okay okay all right uh
some rocks are held together with not
much energy like
if you take a sort of a semi a kind of
solidy thing
like a snowball or so i'm going to get
to that in a minute right oh okay
like a sand ball right right
that if you just sort of punch it the
whole thing just crumbles back into sand
but
it holds its shape together just for a
little while not much energy is holding
that together
snowball another example not much
energy is holding unless you like really
pack it in and what you're doing is
you're melting the snow
and have it re-freeze and that holds it
up better we had a hole
we had a whole explainer on the freezing
and melting of ice
so what you're really doing is saying to
the other person you're having a
snowball fight with
i hate you i hate you even more even
more
because this is going to be a nice
little ice ball that i'm not going to
get in the face with
so that held and if held together only
loosely you can't even throw it without
the thing
flying apart okay so you can write down
how much energy that is
calculate it and write it down now move
the object through space or through the
air
there's a kinetic energy it has
and this is the energy of motion it's
called kinetic energy there's a formula
it's one half times the mass of the
object times the velocity
squared okay all right okay
now the moment the kinetic energy that
the object has
exceeds the binding energy of the
molecules
right you have to ask well if the thing
was going at that speed
and then after it hits it's going at
zero speed
then what happened to all that kinetic
energy it got
pumped back into the object right
but that's more energy than what is
holding the object together in the first
place
right so if you have more kinetic energy
than the binding energy of the thing
that has the kinetic energy
it's going to explode on impact it
explodes
precisely wow so we call these
high-speed collisions
and it's not just oh because it's going
fast no it is higher
speed than the energy that's holding it
together so on impact
it's an explosion and explosions happen
in all directions
now is that because the moon has no
atmosphere because that doesn't happen
on earth
so so so let's i'll get to that in a
minute
okay let me get to that just imagine
there's the air is not a thing just like
okay imagine the air is not
energy talking about the energy okay
okay okay all right
so so there you have it that's the
entire reason so in fact
all the craters on the moon the damn
near all the craters on them there might
be one or two that were volcanic all the
rest
are asteroids uh meteors coming in at
whatever angle
they choose doesn't make a difference
that doesn't make a difference
they all explode on impact they explode
on your pack because they're coming in
at with at what we call a high speed
collision now now let's look at
snowballs
you should try this okay um when you
throw a snowball at a wall the
winter is coming up okay right we're
recording this in november
so you throw it at a wall when it hits
the wall it doesn't stay as a snowball
no it explodes it it basically pops it
goes everywhere
it goes everywhere and except for one
little white dot
so you've done this before yeah okay
this told all hawaii friends and other
friends who
who don't have snowball fights so try
throwing it at different angles
when winter comes you will see that
every time
it explodes on impact and you see the
scatter
all around in equal directions that's
because even at your speed
okay you're not going hypersonic speeds
it's just the speed that you throw it
that's more kinetic energy that is the
binding energy of the snowball
right so that's why a high speed
collision
you have to ask what's binding the
object and how much
energy does it have of motion and it's
the
the relationship of those two numbers
that'll tell you if it's a high-speed
collision
so a snowball on someone's chest
exploding is a high-speed collision
nice that's super cool yeah
yeah and so let's just hope though that
you never throw a snowball hard enough
to leave a crater in somebody
we're gonna have a problem at that point
that would be more energy than is
necessary to explode the
the snowball at the other side but
correct yeah you don't want to be
leaving craters
all right so let's get back to the
atmosphere very important and
interesting question
okay so now an asteroid comes and it
sees the atmosphere
right well the atmosphere is going to
slow it down a bit isn't it okay it's
going to slow it down
if it slows it down enough
so that its kinetic energy is less than
the energy that binds it together
it will survive on impact
right we do find uh meteorites
we add the ite after you that's on the
ground meteor coming through the air
meteorite we find there are meteorites
that make it to the ground
okay wow yeah right we have them they're
there let's go
they slowed down enough put the brakes
on them put the brakes on and it did not
completely explode now in the explosion
there could be some pieces
that remain intact just in the explosion
so
meteor crater arizona which used to be
called barringer crater
and p then geologists said there's got
to be volcanic because it's a perfect
circle
but there's no volcanic activity in
arizona
right there's just no volcano for miles
all right so that was a conundrum when
we figured it out it got renamed
meteor crater and those those computer
simulations were abundant in the early
70s when we were able to
program computers in the science
laboratories so
uh that that asteroid they were saying
well where is the asteroid if an
asteroid did it let's dig and find the
big asteroid
all right and so they dug and they
didn't find anything because they didn't
know
that the sucker blew up okay and so
so a person bought that land a mining
company
bought that land on the expectation that
they could mine
the metals of the asteroid that must be
buried deep in it and it was nowhere
ninety percent of it vaporized on impact
yes
their pieces are scattered around and
and those pieces are now in collections
we have some
at the museum but most of it is gone
for that reason and that's why craters
around there you go
okay another explainer you know we keep
doing this we'll run out of stuff to
explain
that's like reaching the end of the
internet which i
i don't think it's gonna happen or the
end of netflix movies right
right so the next does not happen
that's the that'll be the end of the
world when that's right
all right chuck we got to go thanks for
having me always a pleasure
neil degrasse tyson
[Music]